I'm with Marley's vanderway of Ghent
University Molly's you're here at the
ftth conference and you can talking
about the man degradation now before we
start tell us what that is well most
people always focus on the cost side
when evaluating the fiber to the home
business case and I think that the
revenue side or the demand side is as
important and it is also important to
not just focus on the demand but on when
this amount occurs because the time
value of money decreases and over time
and then you want to have the revenues
in the beginning of your project when
you start deploying or in first years of
deployment rather than having them later
on and this is why demand aggregates are
aggregating the demand up front is
important for the business case I would
say yeah because the revenue is
obviously key to the operators how do
they get to access this demand how do
they do it I think the most important
thing is make it a local story so focus
on the community and focus on what the
community needs try to involve local
community buildings hospitals schools
although it's kind of all those kinds of
institutions and try to convince them
and let them spread the word further so
that is what has been done in a lot of
cases also by google fiber in the u.s.
it's one of the main
so I would say their local thing is
really important yeah so so final sort
of question I mean you've obviously come
here to this to this event and I see a
lot of people trying to put in FTTH are
you confident that if they use demand
aggregation they'll be more successful I
would say from an economic point of view
from a financial point of view I would
say yes and this is also what I'm
presenting tomorrow is the study and
that actually quantifies NPV results and
the present failure results based on the
amount aggregation or no de menthe
aggregation in a couple of cases I be to
the home deployment okay well thanks for
talking to us yeah so demand aggregation
new keywords in FTTH deployment